yeah well as you can see incredibly
dramatic this boat just like so many
others are incredibly overloaded they've
just made the short crossing from Turkey
it's about three miles three and a half
miles and they've landed here on the
beach on the island of Lesvos and
they're now being being helped off
largely by volunteers there are children
here there are elderly women as well and
one by one they're all trying not to
trip as they clamber over the wet rocks
here
incredibly we've been here less than an
hour and this is the third boat we've
seen they used to come in just under
cover of darkness but as you can see now
the demand is so great that right around
the clock these boats keep coming we've
spoken to Afghans we've spoken to
Syrians we've spoken to people from
Bangladesh as well this morning boat
after boat after boat people smugglers
really are doing a waring trade as this
island is overwhelmed it's Dell used by
the number of refugees and migrants
coming on to onto its shores and then we
see what one elderly gentleman there
being carried off what tales are these
people telling of the life that they've
had since they've left these countries
Iraq Afghanistan mainly Syria yeah yeah
this man here looks like he's got an
injured leg you can see that in fact it
could even be broken they're really
struggling here to get him up on see
onto dry land most of the people on
these boats have spent about a week in
Turkey crossing through Turkey from
places such as Syria trying to get to
the coast then paying sometimes
thousands of euros to people smugglers
to make this small journey you can see
this man clearly quite elderly in
distress as well we saw a lady from a
previous boat who really was struggling
and collapsed when she got off a lot of
these people actually quite ill
certainly too ill to be making this
journey but I think it gives you a sense
of the desperation of many of these
people that despite their age
despite this man having a walking stick
it's a journey they're prepared to to
risk the relief is incredible really
when you when you think that these
people have travelled from war-torn
parts of the world to get to Europe and
now they've finally made it no wonder
there are smiles and hugs most of the
people here are volunteers they're a mix
of locals or a mix of people who've come
here specifically to help we've spoken
to some young people who have seen the
scenes on television and just wanted to
come and do their bit and what they are
able to do is hand out water hand out
bananas hand out clothing as well dish
it out to the people on the beaches here
but there's very little else that they
can do other than point them in the
right direction of the port the
situation here is intolerable we spoke
to an aid worker on Sky News yesterday
who said this is a powder keg about to
explode and there are thousands of
people coming
we know the island has around 20,000
refugees on it at the moment but every
day thousands more come and one man told
me he saw yesterday a dozen boats
arrived in an hour and each boat
carrying anything between 20 and 50
people you can see this lady here just
overcome with the emotion of it all it's
desperate to watch I think probably a
mixture of relief and I'm sure gratitude
as well to the people here
it's Island it's just completely unable
to cope it is utterly utterly
overwhelmed you could blame the Greek
government perhaps you could blame the
international authorities you could
blame the wider European state there
isn't any food and water provided
there's no shelter provided there's very
little in the way of twin facilities
there are no showers certainly and
people are having to spend sometimes up
to a fortnight on this island just
trying to get off just trying to get to
Athens the queues are frightening for
getting registrate about registration
documents you need those documents in
order to get on the ferries but then the
queues for the ferry tickets are
impossibly long
so not enough is being done I think you
know it is fair to say not enough is
being done